other than mark cuban laurie is by far
the most sought after shark on shark
tank due to her ability to blow up
products on tv
whether that be the simply fit board or
the scrub daddy if the product is easily
demonstrable lori is often the best
choice
in fact three out of the top five best
performing shark tank deals were with
lori due to this marketing superpower
laurie is often called the queen of qvc
but it's never really made clear how
laurie made her money in the first place
so here's the story of laurie grineer
and how she became the queen of qvc
taking a look back laurie was born on
december 9 1969 in illinois chicago her
father was a real estate developer while
her mother worked as a psychologist
thanks to her parents well-paying
careers laurie never had too much
trouble financially but she did have
some trouble emotionally as her parents
were divorced when she was just 9 years
old anyway as a kid lori's dream was to
be a famous journalist and in turn she
would major in communications with the
focus on journalism television and film
at loyola university while completing
her bachelors lori also got a job by the
chicago tribune presumably as an intern
or an assistant she probably could have
turned this entry level job into a
long-term career but after graduation
lori decided to go down a different path
this included working as a playwright
and a jewelry seller which eventually
led her into designing a plastic earring
organizer in 1996. luckily for laurie
just eight months after creating the
organizer she would successfully sell it
to jcpenney it's not clear how much
jcpenney paid for the invention but we
do know that it was enough for laurie to
pay off for 300 000 loan
with one successful product in the books
lori continued to tinker with cosmetic
organizers jewelry boxes and other small
household items as she turned out new
designs and clever modifications laurie
patented her products and sold them in
various ways sometimes she sold the
rights to her products to big retailers
like jcpenney and other times she
decided to sell her products herself
and back in the day the easiest way to
sell any product was to get it on tv
so in the late 1990s laurie made a deal
with the home shopping network to get
some of her products on air laurie
didn't just go all in on tv though she
also pursued the retail space by getting
her products into bed bath and beyond
all of this allowed her to achieve
moderate success but her biggest jump
forward didn't come till 2000 when she
launched clever and unique creations on
qvc
as you've probably already noticed
laurie is not like the rest of the
sharks and she never really started her
own business she was always more of an
inventor than a businesswoman and she
cleverly played into this with her tv
show the premise of clever and unique
creations is pretty straightforward in
every episode laurie and a few other
hosts review regular household items
with crafty modifications for example
she might review a purse with a slot for
your smartphone or she might review a
mixing bowl with a scooper none of these
products are game changing by any means
but usually they each have their own
little quirks and make life just a bit
easier for the target audience so far
the show has won for 11 seasons which
makes it one of the longest running
shows on qvc
aside from featuring other people's
products on her show given that laurie
is an inventor it's not surprising that
lori often features her own products as
well
nearly all of lori's products are under
a company called for your ease only
you're probably not familiar with this
name as for your ease only it's less of
a brand and more of just a holding
company if you look up the company
you're not going to find a well designed
online store or even much of an online
presence the first links that pop up are
just a bunch of random ebay listings
trying to resell her products though
laurie doesn't use this company as a
marketing or branding tool she does use
it heavily as a filing and litigation
tool
if we scroll through lori's patents the
first thing we'll notice is that she has
loads of patents so far she has a total
of 113 patents the second thing you'll
notice is that most of these patents are
under her company for your ease only
usually these patents are quite broad
and overarching take this fragrance
emitting snow globe pattern for example
the summary of the patent is that it is
a snow globe assembly for emitting a
fragrance to an ambient environment i
assume that this blocks others from
making a snow globe with the same
fragrance emitting mechanism but really
how hard would it be to make a slightly
different mechanism
considering this i'm not really sure how
effective or useful these patents are
not to mention many of these patents
seem to be reaching but i'll let you
guys be the judge of that but anyway now
that laurie had gained some significance
on tv she would start to expand her
business into other sectors
one of the easiest ways to profit off of
your fame is to sell a book and that's
exactly what lori would do
in 2014 laurie launched her book invent
it sell it bank it make your million
dollar idea into a reality as the title
suggests the book discusses how to turn
an invention into a business and how to
turn that business into financial
freedom so far the book has 844 ratings
with the vast majority being positive
but there's a good amount of criticism
as well
one of the biggest critiques seems to be
that lori's book is too broad one
reviewer described that it was like
trying to learn how to create a product
from thirty thousand feet in the air
aside from being too broad other critics
have pointed out that the book doesn't
really teach you how to grow an
invention from scratch to succeed with
lori's strategy you would need at least
one hundred thousand dollars however if
you already have the money and the idea
the book may help you with manufacturing
and scaling
aside from launching a book lori has
also cleverly leveraged her fame to
become a speaker
according to speaker booking agency she
charges between fifty thousand dollars
and one hundred thousand dollars per
speech if you opt for a virtual speech
you might be able to score a speech for
less than 50 thousand dollars honestly
it's not a bad price given that that's
how much you earn from each episode of
shark tank anyway moving into shark tank
lori made her first appearance on the
show in 2012 three years after the show
was started so far she's made a total of
61 deals on air which comes out to a
total of a 9.5 million dollars
unfortunately though lori has the second
lowest closing rate out of all the
regular sharks with less than half of
her deals closing at 48.6
despite the low closing rate it seems
like the ones that do close perform far
better than all the other sharks deals
and that brings us to lori snack for
choosing hero products
amongst all the regular sharks on shark
tank i think lori is by far the most
motivated to find and grow hero products
this is because laurie is the only shark
on the show that's actually trying to
grow her net worth using deals on the
show the rest of the sharks are really
just there for fun most of the time
robert retired 20 years ago and he
entered business again because he was
too bored at home meanwhile kevin could
easily be a billionaire today but he
prefers to preserve his wealth then grow
his wealth and as for mark cuban i think
he just likes being the billionaire on
tv considering this i think it's pretty
clear that laurie takes these
investments the most seriously and
that's why she's the top choice for many
entrepreneurs her deals aren't always
the cheapest in terms of equity but
she's the most willing to get her hands
dirty and actually grow the business
with the entrepreneur and there's no
better proof to this than her home run
products starting with the scrub daddy
the scrub daddy was right up lori's
alley given that it was simply a smart
modification to an everyday product the
entrepreneur only asked for 100 000 in
return for 10 take in the company but
laurie ended up investing two hundred
thousand dollars for a 20 stake since
then laurie has secured scrub daddy
multiple spots on qvc which have
exploded sales she also helped them
expand into big box retailers like
walmart and target and expand
internationally to 17 different
countries thus far scrub daddy has
pulled in a total of 209 million dollars
worth of sales until recently it was the
most successful deal in shark tank
history another one of lori's hero
products was the squatty potty this
product seemed pretty weird at first
glance as it promised to help with the
bowel movements but nonetheless laurie
went ahead and invested 350 000 in
return for 10 of the company since then
this product has turned into the third
most successful deal in shark tank
history pulling in a total of 164
million dollars moving into another mega
hit product we have it simply fit the
board this product was honestly just a
fat exercise product like shake weights
but lori cleverly got in before the
product went exponential which proved to
be extremely profitable she invested a
total of 125 000 for 20 stake in the
company and since then simply fitboard
has pulled in a whopping of 160 million
dollars in lifetime sales some of lori's
other most successful investments
include bantam bagels beverly well bug
bite thing and hug sleep considering all
these successful investments i think
laurie is by far the most successful
investor on shark tank in march of 2020
ori hit a cumulative one billion dollars
worth of sales across all of her shark
tank investments and i believe laurie is
the only shark to achieve this feat as
you would guess all these investments
have made laurie even wealthier and that
brings us to laura's net worth today
just a couple of years ago before all
her shark tank investments blew up
lorri's net worth was estimated to be 50
million dollars
while that's a solid amount it's only
one third of her 150 million net worth
today and honestly i think her net worth
is a lot higher than even that
if we split loy's cumulative one billion
dollars worth of sales over her eight
years on shark tank we get 125 million
per year in revenue but really we can't
split it evenly over the years given
that businesses grow exponentially so a
more realistic estimate would be zero
dollars in annual sales in 2012 and 250
million in annual sales by 2020
basically all of lori's investments are
within the consumer discretionary
industry and the consumer discretionary
companies in s p 500 enjoy a price to
sales ratio of 13.15 even if we estimate
conservatively and give lori's
investments a price to sales ratio of 12
we get a cumulative valuation of 3
billion
this is an extremely conservative
estimate given that everly will itself
just complete a funding round with a 2.9
billion evaluation
anyway lori's median stake comes in at
17 percent
even if we assume that she gets watered
down to 10 on average that's 300 million
worth of equity just from shark tank
deals combine this with everything else
she does and i think 300 to 500 million
dollars is a much more reasonable net
worth estimate for lori and at the rate
she's been growing it's just a matter of
time until she gets the billion dollar
net worth mark and that's how laurie
became the queen of qvc are you guys a
fan of lori comment that down below also
drop a like if you're rooting for lori
and of course consider joining our
discord community to suggest future
video ideas and consider subscribing and
see more questions logically answered
but until then i'm hari and i'll see you
guys on the next one